you
yeah hello and welcome to the stream
anybody around yet I see that I'm under
I'm on the front page
oh I'm advertised in candor that I'm
doing stuff on the candidates whom I
don't know this is just my Monday live
show actually I can't do something when
the candidates though I mean it's
definitely possible
anybody see what I'm very high okay I
hope you're all right should I do
something on the candidates it's one
option I can also play some stuff play
some some tournament I can do some the
u're games I'm very much open for
discussion we had some really cool games
I mean today how did it end actually
Mahmoud Yara of Khurana was probably a
draw right or did that have a winner
I did not even check to be honest yeah
it's nice one you just okay so um what
am I going to do how did that game Quran
I'm a MIDI Aravind I guess in a draw but
I'm not really certain I did not see the
end of it how did that end can anybody
tell me
did Ellie dinner draw okay yeah it
looked look like it should end in a draw
absolutely okay so um what what is the
general opinion Shan Shan Shan look at
the crown Nikki game from today that was
probably the most interesting game but
I'm also happy with playing a little bit
of light-hearted games if anybody is
interested I've had a pretty busy day
because I had the new Evo repertoire
released on chasuble today which was
tons of work really and I'm happy it is
out so I should look at the crown net
game we do have a candidates we do have
a candidates study here right candidates
round three it was the game no that's
not the game
so this is roma and chronic rooney and
chronic game does that really look okay
i think it looks okay right you see if
you see what you need to see this is
usually this is my view for tournament
play usually but i think it's ok i you
see the board you see the the moves on
the right hand side if the engine is on
which we can use or not i can flip the
board yeah I can definitely do that
let's do it we've got it covered from
the black side yeah thanks for the
feedback there are already some people
in who bought the e for repertoire ok
I'm going to start to look at this game
in in a moment I just got I just have
gotten a message that I quickly need to
look at I mean only it will only take
like 30 seconds so I'm sorry but
you
we have we have aronia and sorry yeah
yeah have unmuted um so we have Aronian
playing white and the very first
surprise as this one efore yeah this is
not what Rania usually plays and it's
something that actually managed
mentioned earlier that that we that we
had earlier at Aronian is usually not
going to play afore he usually goes d4
or C form those eyes main opening moves
and e4 has a bit of a surprise he only
does that very very rarely
okay not much of surprises that kramnik
stops that Kramnik is yeah is playing
his main main repertoire choice the
Berlin defence he sticks to his guns and
Aronian gaze goes d3 so he plays them d3
anti-villain yeah the ultimate entire
Berlin is by the way one D form or C
form probably but okay let's see what
happens d3 um in the very beginning it
was basically clear that white should
search for an advantage with castles and
then they get to the ending you know the
famous Berlin ending that in fact
yesterday Kramnik played with the white
pieces against well thanks for for the
subscription that Kramnik played with
the white piece against kayaking tried
to press water out of stone for quite a
while the ending is still um regularly
played but I think black is reasonably
happy about about his chances them the
mostly three years probably the one that
keeps the most pieces on the board it is
not a very energetic choice though it's
not the kind of move that you will wipe
out black with in general we see lots of
those slowest variations in nowadays d3
and the italian d3 and in the way and so
on it just shows that with the forcing
variations you have trouble getting much
yeah he black needs to worry a little
bit about the e5 pawn
therefore he plays d6 to cover the pawn
or more actively Bishop c5 Bishop c5 is
the main move that tries to develop
outside of the pawn chain and be active
on that diagonal this is some yeah you
don't see kramnik at the bottom there I
know this is because I'm currently using
my setup that I usually use I can adjust
it slightly I usually use that for
tournaments and not for these kind of
analysis reviews but I think it's better
now etiquette could adjust it and so the
bishop is on a strong diagonal there and
this is something that we would see in
the game that this bishop is as a
dangerous dangerous piece here White has
a couple of choices he can also play
moves like c3 or castles castles is
however I think usually deemed as rather
lame as Black has got 94 available that
would trait mine a piece that I think
makes it relatively easy
c3 is also again a mainline Aronian
decides to take and gets to this rather
static pawn structure first thing to
notice that this is not hanging yeah
here black can play Queen to deform that
actually it's the best move right yeah a
queen to deform yeah that doesn't win a
piece straight away because we should be
three Queen takes d4 which would get the
piece back but you have like this of
course
winning normalize it I think it's fairly
convincing now what is why do Aronian
actually castles yeah and which is of
course a completely normal looking move
however um what I felt when I looked at
this a little bit not this game in
particular but those structures I felt
it is interesting for white not to
commit so early on to canceling short so
if you want me to give out a
recommendation they're not talking about
a recommendation that will refute the
Berlin or something maybe an expert or
real expert this may be the wrong word
but a real yes super strong player who
knows the building and out maybe would
say yeah that isn't so dangerous but my
view of this is I've seen some games
where White has been more flexible with
the King position and sometimes long
castling gets played and then white
tries to advance like that there has
been a very well-known game between o ye
and was like I think was navara and I
think that Muslim was the pairing where
ye got a very strong attack here on the
King side and just I think an
interesting choice Ronia not ever
castles and Kramnik plays Queen to you
several covering this pawn and now we
come to an interesting point and this
interesting point is really happening
now because aronia now plays the move h3
wretchedly quickly and I know it sounds
a bit wacky but this is this is probably
not good and it's probably not good
because of what happens now and this is
really the next move I can absolutely
assure you
would have never ever ever ever ever
been played 20 years ago 10 years ago or
or if you go even further back it's it's
completely out of the out of the picture
that this could have happened because
chronic now plays the shocking new
troupe to g8 and if you see that for the
very first time you would think that
what happened yeah yeah too much brandy
or something or I don't know what is
typical of Berlin yeah I do they have
some strong alcoholic beverage I don't
know we have what what exactly did he
consumed to play route g8 yeah g8 is not
a novelty by Geary but it's just what
stockfish gives as the best move yeah
it's just if you run this through the
engine and you give it time it says
Route g8 best move like it's slightly
better I know that is some very shocking
but I tested it yeah I mean I wanted to
check really if that is true not you get
into stockfish it it shows the move
relatively quickly as possible which is
in itself pretty shocking in a way and
then if you give it some time and then I
did run like half an hour yeah when
while I was making my mouth fixing my my
dinner
it gives Luke g8 really as the clearly
strongest move with an advantage for
black which is I feel extremely shocking
so I know it sounds harsh but that that
was really bad preparation by aronia so
what is the idea g5 yeah black wants to
go d5 and this is the shocking thing
about this is that actually black is
playing this with out playing h6 this is
this is the most shocking to me
something like h6
and attending g5 this is something that
you sometimes see in lines I've played
this way myself in the in the Italian
game many times which is really a
different kind of position because their
submission one c4 and so on but in
general the idea to pawn storm we
the Jeep horn against h3 it's not
entirely that's all I know but what I
feel is really shocking that you can
actually save the move h6 the point is
what is White's move now if you place
for example something that you often
does like Knight B to d2 then you can do
this in one go yeah you can even save
the move h6 because now there's not
enough on that on that on their porn by
the way bad bishops thanks a lot for the
donation yeah I'm happy to do some
candidates coverage so this is really
great yeah Luke g8 but I'm totally sure
that this is not a move that you would
come up as a human player you have to
see it beforehand and and in the in the
in the chat they say that chronic said
he forgot his prep after Knight h5 his
memory was unclear 9 h5 is the next move
that is very very that is very much
possible that he at some point had
analyzed this but he certainly did not
expect this to happen today as aronia
doesn't play for at all and it's
probably not something that you would
inspect expect in general because that
specific move order with h3 early is not
super frequent no it's not super
frequently seen but honestly I know it
sounds harsh but if you play this with
why do you have to know this
I mean if stopped which keeps that as
the number one choice not knowing this
on move 7 is really not good I mean hmm
yeah ok but what goes on now what I
found very surprising when I saw this
the the the time spent have a look at
this aronia and 138 yep so his spent
like 2 minutes or something up to this
point which I understand the no g8 comes
and the next move he goes King h1 okay
he had says 13 minutes okay then then
then he is there's a different time
stamp then the one I saw on chess 24
because I looked at this a little bit on
chess 24
and it's it displayed displayed that he
would that he would have played this in
two minutes which I would found shocking
if somebody would play rook g8 against
me I would yeah definitely think for
Morty and like oh my god what the heck
is going on because you know that this
is Kramnik doe doesn't play rook GA just
on a whim yeah he he would have prepared
this stuff and you have to take awhile
to figure out a reply
so King edge one yellow - whoops yeah
and to plan a chess club and thanks for
the cheer so King edge one he took he
took a while okay KH one is the kind of
move that can that be the best I don't
know I did not check this game with an
engine really I just looked at it and
was was stunned what happened okay King
- h1 and okay one point is certainly
that the king is getting out of this out
of this bishops diagonal one thing you
also have to see if white tries to trade
this him again g5 can be played in one
move and the next moves the G file is
open don't underestimate how quick this
attack can develop you go G form
yeah the H Ponzi pond gets traded bishop
comes out and next move we have
cancelled long I mean this is really a
really a quick attack brewing and I
think what what Svidler said you are in
the broadcast which i watched briefly
yeah it's it doesn't feel good if you
have this idea of getting checkmated
after move seven on the white side on
the end in I think really this is what
you feel like I have to look to a dealer
oh my god I could get checkmated today
and okay so King edge one was played not
sure that this is the most critical move
but it's it's tough to say really
so tonight aged five and this is now
opening this up so that g5 can be played
in one move
yeah just in one move you can go g5g for
and this is all due to h3 yeah it's um
really is something that it's
underestimated that early age three move
when you have canceled and the other
side has not it is just completely
astonishing that this is working so
quickly here in this game so I know to
kramnik student yeah you must have been
delighted today right okay so the night
goes to h5 and this prepares g5 and now
c3 this is really looking slow but it
looks like something that makes sense
yet strike back in the center it stuffed
it's really tough to say what's better
here I mean you cannot go this should be
three now that is blundering directly so
what you have to be actually play
sometimes sometimes you just have to go
on with the exclusion method so what
works and what doesn't
one thing I just wondered is is it
actually a threat I mean there's ninety
eighty five so let's just assume let's
just try out yeah if we develop with
Knight c3 not sure that this helps much
yeah the knight is not good on that
square anyway yeah
no beef I have no d5 the only idea of it
would be to go to e2 in order to defend
just a matter of getting defensive
pieces um it's g5 actually possible its
Knight takes e5 an issue there
I don't know that all could work
oh thanks for the donation thank you
sorry if I take actually Queen takes do
have something I don't think so I cannot
go g-form right away and this is
probably going to be answered with f
phone that doesn't work but this is
probably the clue depth here this is
going to be very very dangerous now
which is probably a euphemism yeah I'm
attacking this with black and what do
you do okay we're getting somewhere
if white takes here we are checking and
over mate this bishop is very very
dangerous and the same thing happens
here and next move mate Wow so this is a
bit of a disaster this is still this is
hanging I mean this is the bad thing I
mean you're not just going to be
attacked this Knight is also just
hanging I hope I'm right on that
assumption but I think I'm right now
that this is stuck here I'm going to
once in a while check with the engine so
G 595 g-force g-force aw yeah the engine
actually says deforested of position but
depth 21 mmm-hmm I wouldn't trust so
much
it's the only player will move the or
deform and now yeah this is something
where I'm ultimately the engine will
definitely display the absolute truth
for sure the question is how long does
it take to make that calculation Bishop
d6 looks good yeah yeah that is
definitely a good position the line that
is given here by the engine for example
yeah this is a disaster the the it gives
equal but you know this is just terrible
looking for white it looks terrible
you've got this castle here and then you
put the bishop on that diagonal I think
this is also what the engine wants to do
that looks pretty awful maybe you have
enough counterplay on the dark squares
but it looks very difficult to play the
whole position is of course absolutely a
nightmare in a practical game but it
feels like you stumbled right into the
petroleum with this thing
amazing amazing Aronian plate c3 after a
long thing ng5 are the same the same
thing happens yeah Cromley prepared well
that is probably true I mean but one
thing is clear this can be the kind of
thing in the sukkah g8 that that he is
sitting there for ages and hopes that it
one day gets on the board and it must
have feel like like Christmas and and
the birthday and everything combined
yeah and one at one time and when when
you get this on the board yeah I mean
even if it is yeah there's some weird
line that equalizes for white again that
is a nightmare to him on the board yeah
I did not view the crumb except his head
this normally prepared for a long time I
can easily imagine because it is short
by the engine yeah it is short by the
engine and sometimes those things I
think are sitting there on the
on the shelf and then you just hope that
you get it at one time yeah and this
happened in the in the most important
game maybe yeah that you can that you
can get it on the board yeah fantastic
for Chrome Nick yeah he has a great
chance now even after only three rounds
we can say that this is shaping up
nicely it's got two wins already in the
back end he's I mean he is extremely
extremely experienced there he has
beaten Kasparov an image is the kind of
person if he gets to plus 3 or plus 4 he
can simply bunker this down to the end
yeah and win and win the whole thing
yeah he's not going to be nervous or
something and that's not happening I
mean the Zakai because far off without
losing a game so mg5 Knight takes e5 and
then g4 yeah and now you're sitting
there and we have the same lines as
beforehand white cannot take because
this is over
note that Bishop iam very nice and here
you're going to going to win as well so
Aronian went deform instead which makes
sense block this diagonal Bishop d6
again you cannot take on G for them this
is fairly fairly clear something like
this is also made so G 3 it makes sense
it's tough to me enough for me now to
work out when this is really objectively
terrible like I mean this this looks bad
it looks bad but how bad is it yeah it's
tough to say for me just like by looking
at it what does the engine say I really
need some help there it cause it's such
an unconventional position it gives like
some some advantage that it's not a
surprise but the the point is how much
is it yeah
Queen deform yeah that looks it looks
quite logical yeah push the Queen back
on the other hand yes you're sitting
right into c-5m are you walking right
into c5 okay edge form that you probably
have to do then c5 and thanks for
subscribing aesthetic broccoli it's
really cool username you like broccoli
it's supposed to be very very healthy
and I'm not eating it often enough I
think so c5 attacks the Queen Queen c4
he's giving a ton of checks and now f5 I
know I mean the dead I can say I know
that after f5 black is supposed to be
winning
according to stock fish that's something
that has spotted on the chest 24 website
when I first opened up the game today
they had to position on the board
exactly this position and it was the
engine was giving +3 to Kramnik so Queen
c4 Queen a for those who are bad yeah so
here I'm Roni instill could affirm
got a playable somewhat playable
position you say so what else should you
have done instead of Queens waveform I
mean the whole thing is really super
annoying and yeah you don't have don't
have those pieces out yeah Queen d3 is
better you save you creator probably
probably you need to be able to answer
f5 was taking and after check now you
will trade the Queens at least I mean
that position is still not good for
white but yeah that looks like a
playable collage that's not lost in me
at him but here there are other options
here you can even go here let's say rook
d3 the light squares absolutely terrible
in whites camp he's got this fairly
useless bishop and he's not really
shoring up the light squares yak-1 ds3
and I can go that prevents f5 maybe I
mean I'm not sure it really prevents it
technically I could still do it and
probably have have some kind of
compensation but this year why not
recreate something bad about that and
the engine gives 58
and we should suffice I had this on the
board there and then so it's it's it's
it's crazy yeah six novices Cromley
played the strongest group every time
after that position yeah I guess and
every thing is this is not exactly
rocket science yeah it is just like you
you spot the active move and you see
that I mean if you calculate this this
is not so difficult because he's sitting
there with all those non pieces that
makes it really easy to calculate in a
way because there are not many
possibilities I'm not saying that was an
easy job or so they were saying finding
the best move here
the absolutely best move is not so
difficult because it's not a maze of
variations where tons of things are
possible for example after f5 Bishop g5
you don't need to calculate you just
smash it and player 4 it must be right
you are taking now with absolutely
anything here and what is why doing them
I mean this you can easily evaluate as a
win Queen to the 1m rook e8 Quincy one
yeah for the disaster oh my god
ha yeah I'm just thinking about this
game and wonder if huronian can come
back from that this is such a disastrous
loss they I mean this is the kind of
game where when you lose like this the
the main thing that you need there is on
the next round some sort of fluke win
yet you need to get back into it
immediately and forget about the game
yeah
ha what is wrong and who is he playing
tomorrow can you tell me when I would
the only the chance would be wesayso or
something yeah play against so was in
into completely rotten form and know I
think aronia knew that he was asked
before and that's the rest day hmm
that's the rest day ok yeah but he needs
you need some he needs something
something simple yeah I mean not simple
and that's wrong but somebody was also
in bad shape this is what I just want to
say yeah I think it was clear to him
after f5 that he's toast probably before
it looks pretty rotten you have nothing
develop your light squares are well yeah
ok so this this this f4 Queen d1 opti 18
c1 and yeah now black simply 2 or g3 and
why not white cannot recapture and what
exactly is your movie play tonight
a3 yeah very strong using this
potentially on them on the third-ranked
yeah I know Bishop d5 is such a smash
yeah let's move that you really like to
play play Bishop defy again you get up
you grab a coffee
yeah and kramnik I don't know I think
he's still enjoying the odd cigarettes
nowadays yeah that's really the kind of
move
makes you feel really well so f3 was
played now let's have a look what
exactly happens if white takes the
material so if the rook gets taken how
does black actually win what do you
think what's the win IAM
do you know what to witness any
suggestion let's make this a little bit
interactive just qui takes okay
and here and now do we have what what's
the winner probably we can do it in the
pedestrian way yeah by taking in the
rook I wondered I mean just saying is
that also winning I mean this is a very
cute made you know I just saw this and I
felt mmm yeah he said it said possible
it looks it looks strong but it could
have some kind of drawback this is just
cute and I don't really see a way for
why to defend you that that how should
that look like yeah we're threatening f2
with all with all my gym it's a win
right don't tell me it doesn't work yeah
it's made in force so context is not bad
yeah made in five ok so this is the
reputation of rook takes Queen takes is
leading to a maid and if the bishop gets
taken how do we win then I want to
switch it off yeah it should be and it's
some kind of challenge so how are we
going to win here probably there's some
simple way but maybe we have a beautiful
way well I mean I see a mate and except
some something simple but it's there is
there something better available ok if
you see one made it's enough so I think
this would probably be enough yeah this
is a major is there quicker mate than
this I don't I'm not sure I'm not seeing
it at least like here
yeah this will be a major something like
that it's just check check check and
made maybe there is something quicker
now you have to check though
and maybe there's something even quicker
g3 maybe then king g1 I don't think that
is on you but Queen f3 is checkmate yeah
that that's got to be a win it's the end
Ian seeing anything better
Queenie form k1 takes takes rook g3 hmm
okay okay that's a nice one it's
actually quite nice yeah with this this
point but the check check check is also
winning so back to Bishop d5 and so this
is now simply threatening oops
man it's retina here by the way I've got
a question if you use religious studies
M if I want to unpainted acero is there
a simple way to do it I tend to click on
some some square that has no piece that
that can go to it that would uh narrow
yeah like I'd make the arrow and I click
click the say on a Foursquare but it's
kind of kind of weird is that some other
way to simply delete if I have right all
kind of stuff and then escape no that
doesn't work
yeah I can redraw the arrow then it's
kind of lame I mean I think it's about
no I've lost all the variations I was no
my issue is that whenever now let's say
I paint all kinds of stuff now if I left
click yeah you know I can I can paint
and I know what what I can click let's
say on a edge you know on an unrelated
square left click then I under all
arrows yeah but I need to left-click
something that cannot be painted and
something that cannot be moved so if I
paint all kinds of stuff let's say and
it's white and I click on every year
then it makes the move yeah I need to
yeah but you need to find them to square
this is sometimes a little bit of an
issue like if I record a video and I
paint all over the place and then I'm in
the middle of telling these people
things and when I produced videos I
really have to check like let's see you
let's see this where is the empty square
yeah I mean I will find it but okay
there doesn't seem to be anything
simpler like it would be actually not
bad if you let's say press X or so and
then as everything is gone anyway Bishop
d5 white plate f3 and now crumb Nick
just took with the pawn yeah this is
this is the stuff of dreams and you have
those two pawns here it's great yeah and
note that after rook takes Queen takes
which ones pose into the line that we
had seen before with the beautiful mate
yeah very cute so here this was played
by Aronian we're already in the beyond
repair zone of course by far and now
Queen to be two very nicely
yeah threatening made on those squares
rook e1 is the only one this is already
made in X right here made in 7 look even
on G to check King H 2 G 1 yeah somebody
said that the game was already finished
here and then one resides here after G 1
Queen that is definitely making sense
yeah that he did not play it out until
the mate was actually on the board yeah
yeah that looked terrible aronia was
really completely completely annihilated
here with the white pieces
what an unlucky what an unlucky game in
some way I'm you play you play you play
like this yeah with 83 and I don't know
then then Ruchi eight hits you who I
mean in some way this is just bad bad
preparation by Rania
this is what the engine gives and
Kramnik students said that it has been
played in correspondence chess which is
not making it any any better really very
difficult for wrong yet I mean it is not
yet over
it's really not the case but he has to
win a game quite quickly also simply to
get back back on track somehow this is
the kind of defeat that makes you really
really feel miserable yeah you try to
surprise the opponent with white yeah by
going for I mean the thing is yeah it is
a surprise for the game but this is
Chrome Knicks let's say as we say in
German bread-and-butter opening yeah
it's the kind of thing that you that you
play if you get yeah somebody wakes you
up in the night yeah and and okay
playing a game if you wake me up at 3 in
the morning yeah I play I play my my old
runo pass line that I've played a
million times it's just like what is in
my DNA and what Kramnik Kramnik has the
Berlin in his DNA yeah it's just that
it's just that you try to he try to play
exactly or chronics playing field yeah
[Music]
yeah this is is a disaster ready and it
happened to you so Aronian definitely
has to get back on track he's got the
rest day and who's he playing in round
form I would really like to know that
anybody willing to check I mean I don't
want to switch the
here the view too much and go on to go
on to other sides who is he facing in
round four kayaking with black softly
hmm
it doesn't sound too too great kayaking
with black is a bit like banging your
head against the wall but ki KEK I can
also has to win a game yeah I mean it
sometimes doesn't look like he ever
wants to but yeah he has to he has to
try and maybe this is not a bad bad
pairing for Aronian definitely kramnik
will try something else and um and let's
see if chrome next wins this tournament
I think this is going to be an
interesting match definitely I mean that
is that it's not going to be easy going
accountant is the favorite anyway no
matter who is playing it really doesn't
matter it's his match the matches for
him to lose not for the other guy to win
the from NICUs if Carson is playing in
top shape he will win anyway but if that
is not the case
chrome dick is certainly somebody who's
got all the other things necessary to do
to win yeah absolutely
okay so we looked at this game and the
other games today I don't think they
were super exciting you know the Soudan
game was like it was theory all the way
and then some boring ending this is this
kind of games
the reason why I never played the
Marshall attack with black I always feel
if you play against a competent opponent
you're just playing for two results and
the winners start one of them
this is this is something that Blackie
and her Woodman will never win no
absolutely I think kramnik is an
attractive opponent I mean absolutely
that is he is far more interesting to
watch this match then then some other
opponents absolutely it's so it's still
the case that it's it's Carlton Carlton
needs to lose the match it's not so much
that the other guy is just stronger yeah
you have
they've been cases of virtue it should
match us where you just know I mean some
people some somebody is a favorite yeah
and in this case a cousin is still the
favorite to win but from Nick is
certainly able to to use weakness yeah
absolutely
and then it would be very interesting I
mean chronic for example if he's leading
in the match I'm not sure it's going to
then give that back yeah because if it
doesn't want to lose it's very tough to
beat okay so I think this is kind of an
on game to be honest this is theory for
a very long time up to this ending and
even deeper I think where black will
draw with the bishops versus the bad
pawn structure it's um I think what's
owed it here is just playing playing for
to result say he had this to offer
losses and he wanted to go for something
safe probably I'm not sure if King is
playing the marshal and this was part of
preparation yeah delicious woody very
nice yeah yeah leeches was kind enough
to send me that for free it's a very
nice one I really like it they sent it
to me for free already like month ago a
long time ago but this thing actually
never fitted me and now that I've lost a
bit of weight I can actually wear it
it's nice so I don't think this is super
interesting it's it's a bunch of prep
and then we go into and
so koala mama Jeff was actually M was
actually quite exciting I haven't seen
the game 49 yeah shall we look at this
I'll do something more lighthearted Jeff
what what do you think I want I want to
stream for roughly from here on like an
hour a little bit more because I
definitely definitely need some sleep
but yeah do we want to look at this a
little bit shall we do some some viewer
games okay I can look through it I'm
happy to do so
let's let's have a look then we have
first of all let me kind of think about
this pairing it a little bit Caruana is
mostly an e4 player so this was expected
he plays everything
yeah but he's mostly playing one e4 so
moment you are off playing the night off
it's not something you would naturally
expect I mean it's part of his
repertoire as far as I know but he's
playing more more of 55 slightly I
really liked his round one opening you
know this is something that I have on
the radar for a long time he played it
around when he played this g6 line
against kayaking and one I actually have
this on my repertoire which is a little
bit different but quite interesting to
check so I like those somewhat obscure
obscure s bit strong but let's say side
lines of 45 there are oftentimes quite
interesting to play okay this time I'm
Adyar off went for the night off
f3 is plate yeah f3 is um
relatively still relatively young move
in this position it basically became
prominent once they worked out that
after Bishop III signaling why its
intention to probably play Queen d2 f3
and long for the English Tech once they
realize that Nigel was actually quite a
decent move not that it is better for
black or so but it's something that I
think black is quite happy with as far
as I know and therefore why players
began to start with f3 and only then
clay Bishop b3 there are some
differences here of course you are
committing to f3 very early on if you
play Bishop III you have some odd lines
where you omit the move now okay here if
v was played this is for example an
instant we're having f3 on the board
already is quite interesting for black
yeah if you for example there is this
and I have to say I'm not an expert yeah
but I just want to show you there are
additional things like this one after
this why does not have to play with f3
necessarily he can for example still
switch back to Bishop b2 and Castle or
he can sometimes play a form and in some
situations so there are some points them
okay f-35 Bishop 6 you should be 722
right bd7
they are definitely move out of wrinkles
but I'm I have to admit that I cannot
help you there
yeah I would have to look into a
database and check check things because
this open Sicilian is not my usual area
where I wear analyzed here in the night
off for Wyatt if people ask me I usually
recommend Age 3 but I don't know the
other line said well so
yeah folks yeah six hours of work isn't
that much the problem is and that is
what sometimes is underestimated it's
not just the six hours at the board
they are exhausting but they have to
prepare this is by the way a huge
difference to to to chess 4050 years ago
though they didn't prepare I mean they
just sit at the ball in play yeah I mean
there are funny stories yeah when when I
read about the Spassky fishermen said
when Spassky was preparing for the match
and I mean they knew that was a
something where I mean that was
something that mattered to the whole
USSR yeah and people wanted Spassky to
to beat that bloody American and they
had people from the KGB from The Secret
Service whatever he had come to ask his
training camp yeah and they found all
those grandmasters there drinking vodka
and smoking yeah and I can tell you this
is not happening nowadays it doesn't it
just just doesn't happen
yeah because they have to work their
asses off and it's just impossible to do
this kind of thing yeah anyway castles
g5 Knight h5 yeah though this is really
true then it's not just some random
story and they have been books about the
match and they have been that they sent
people from the KGB check on the
training camps and it must have been a
complete mess yeah and like bottles all
over the place and so on it sounded
crazy and nowadays they work their asses
off they really do so okay b5 here and
95 I know that this structure is quite
common actually in them in those lines
and one thing to notice that one thing
to note is that the black camp suffers
from from white squared light squared
weaknesses
see six for example and as we will see
f6 is played now by Mohammed Europe that
actually weakens more so the light
squares are weakened and the weaknesses
are mostly on the center and on the
queenside and what I know is that mostly
why it is not playing on the kingside
here as this g45 would suggest would
rather try to play on the light squares
I think we would see something about
that I mean this bishop we maybe go here
and black will go Knight f4 yeah sorry
that's a good question yeah Queen takes
d5 I think blonde does g5 is the problem
Queen d5 is from a strategic point of
view and interesting move but you give
away g5 and it's always checked so you
have problems yeah I definitely Fisher
worked extremely seriously compared to
the Russian camp I guess so this
wouldn't work these are all subtleties
if white and I'm not sure how this would
be possible but if white would have have
the roof here already or h4 on then you
would be able to take on d5 here black
goes Knight f4 this is important to note
black always has this f4 square for the
knight as white cannot really take on
air form if you take them you make this
bishop extremely strong I mean here you
can take the pawn but black will grab
here I think and in general you don't
take that
kramnik said he only had one training
camp during the last four years um
I mean he can't do many things without a
training camp and one thing is with
chronic um he does not play that much
anymore
he does he plays less he focuses more on
some important events and I mean you
have to see he's gotten the wild-card
for this tournament he did not qualify
so it's not like he's the most active
player anymore compared to what he used
to do but I think the moment you get
this wild card here you certainly yeah
you get the wipe again here something is
going on there it's serious
anyway Group g1 King h8 makes sense
again out of any LightSquared chicks and
why decentralizing interesting choice
now Bishop g5 to h6 this is surprising
hmm that's a surprising move actually
the reason why I'm surprised is you
don't have to play it in some way
because I mean why can never take
strategically speaking him he cannot
continue not take yeah sure there's a
reason the reason could be money but the
reason for people like from [ __ ] are
in here if he is not he did he's not the
kind of person I would assume who spend
all the money that he heard on some
nonsense he would have done some good
investments I think and he doesn't
really need the money but getting
getting a match he had to be in the
limelight again against one of the best
players of all time yeah that's really
really a great motivation and if he
would somehow because they're just
speculation that would be one of the
strongest chess efforts of all time
really absolutely so why not anyway
Bishop g5 I'm surprised because why
never threatened to take there but maybe
I see what the next moves are black is
going to age six and go screen age for
it does make some sense
note that white is indeed playing on the
queenside it's got the knight to c6 and
black Queen to h4 wow that's
super-complicated disposition
Queen before I had some date xt6 okay I
need to really understand this a little
bit I only know that at the end yeah
they had an ending where Mohammed Deif
was the exchange down but had to Ted
some pawns but I have no clue how the
game went thanks for following okay
let's have a look at the screen before
it makes sense yeah I take this the
knight is pinned so it cannot take
Andrew kf6 was some reaction simply
covering that pawn and now a fall okay
yeah the first point of a4 is that I
guess at least you cannot take it as
this would drop material yeah that's a
simple double attack and momiji are off
to carnage - Wow
you know what I like is that they
actually play this kind of game here I
mean they are both sitting very
comfortably on a plus one score and
still they go out for a real fight this
is something that I like with both
players they they are not very much of
course they watch the tournament
standings and they are kind of their
tactical about things yeah in a way yeah
like is a draw okay and so on everybody
does look at look at it in this way but
they still want to just play the best
possible moves and try to play
enterprising ly so this is a real fight
yeah that's not some scared chess not at
all okay Queen takes Bishop Eve form
yeah okay
d5 was hanging not now because of the
pin but after the Queen capture this was
in fact hanging okay so now he has to
look at this first even though that is
not really a threat right
I mean takes there's queenie for home
just try to understand here visually
before I mean Bishop before does not
make a bad impression anyway I'm just
thinking it's 1965 really a threat but
what else should white play I mean just
for fun if you take here and I can't
take on no we can just take here right
this is the blonde layer of course sorry
yeah pawn takes this is hanging and rook
takes this is hanging no it's not
hanging who well this is this is one one
problem here at least yeah nine takes
thought this year for maid
and if this doesn't work I mean I can
cheat for once yeah but it doesn't work
at 24 wins but night xt3 doesn't eat the
problem as the engine confirms yeah I
still like it yeah that I cannot use my
traditional sex sex explained yeah just
explained you to the SE X today it's
it's I think it's fun let's keep it like
that and they cannot change it yeah that
they cannot they cannot change it I
asked them once yeah but once the the
thing is established you have to keep
the channel name and it's okay it's not
a big deal so Bishop before he just
makes sure that the bishop cannot be
taken and it covers everything nicely
again black cannot take on a form
well you can take you can change it and
maybe you still cannot change it to the
to the SE exam anyway let's have a look
there Kru 64 don't you have a youtube
channel yourself
hello welcome to the chat now you have
something yourself right I saw you
recently I mean I didn't watch the
stream and I saw that you are on
streaming so welcome to streaming on HS
if you knew happy to see new strong
challenge good channels coming coming
coming to DHS
yeah cool so okay Queenie - I need to
really this is this is not my kind of
position and I have no yeah you did
don't see it at first yeah that the
channel here's a little bit a little bit
different okay
so let's have a look at the game Queenie
- was played and look what happens here
I want to mess him okay this is hanging
and he simply takes that it's not much
else you know there's not much else so
white takes on f4 okay you should takes
so what what happens yeah yeah so mama D
ro snatch the edge to pawn and white in
the meantime gets him the game of chess
needs more bald-headed middle-aged men
middle-aged what is middle-aged don't I
look young for my age I think I do
but probably not something to discuss
anyway queen 85 wanted to go to c7 White
has to get some initiative going when he
has good pieces yeah he lost upon but
the knight on c6 is strong the bishop on
e4 strong and you have some ideas also
here it's a mean blacks extra pawn is
the H pawn and that is not easily pushed
it's not you have an easy technical
winning idea so 95 was played Queen to
c7
yeah that's some weird idea say I move
the night that's true it's suggested in
the chat like oh here or here and trying
to trap something I don't think you need
a particular rating to visit a chess
club just go with them I mean people
that chest clubs are just chess players
yeah they're kind of crazy maybe a
little bit weird but well it's what it
is just go there don't worry
so black played Bishop to h6 why exactly
mate so he just stopped the mate that
makes sense okay and now Knight to d8
that's funny but this makes sense you
have this and this idea
so let's go check on e4 hmm what's that
necessary now I went to undraw and no I
don't manage so he took on a form
okay now Knight f7 doesn't really help
us black can just take it and here rook
F ain't taking this okay ya know 90 f7
was winning the exchange which probably
yeah yeah I actually want to do this
yeah okay when the engine likes white
here hmm but this is the kind of
position where it will probably yeah the
engine now makes any human player look
bad because it is just so so technical
and complicated here look D to e one
suggested by the computer I mean that
makes some sense it does make some sense
first do this and then check here this
is a way to cover the check but then
ninety six looks good
well it looks good for white that looks
good for white but Tehran I wanted to
win the exchange which I find very
understandable and here maybe he didn't
really appreciate Roxy a door that much
that intermediate move like here Queen
b7 that's a strong on Queen B sound no
Queenie six Queenie six to stop that and
then you go rook df1 and then continue
to attack well it's tough it's
definitely that the zelenov is tough
white White's supposed to be winning
here engine-wise but it's it's the tough
position so rook c8
no you have to cover this and okay
there's a little trap so not that one
Queen takes and I'm a bit surprised that
the engine is still liking white so much
black it's got two pawns for the
exchange and this position doesn't seem
so badly coordinated I just wonder what
the point eight five is given by the
conch trying to maybe fix that pawn and
win it later
hmm it doesn't it doesn't look look to
me all that clear
I mean 1.5 what what the computer gives
us kind of like okay what's winning but
it's really tough it's really tough I
mean there are bad pawns all over the
place maybe you win a six quickly but I
mean this is what the engine gives and I
mean the moment you want to take here
you can take c1 so it takes almost like
this maybe this is an idea
the computer is probably right that
white is clearly better I'm not going to
I don't think that kind of the engine is
weak that is it is stockfish and the
depth is quite reasonable I think it's
quite okay yeah I can believe that white
is much better here
engine-wise but it is very difficult to
play so this was played became
threatening mate so so he was happy to
repeat for the moment didn't understand
a lot and black goes whoop g8 not
repeating okay well that's a that's a
cool decision I'm like wow this is
really cool to see Renee if she wants to
continue to fight here and not just make
a draw which would probably have
happened if Khurana was very low on time
the position might have been better for
white okay but I would fully understand
if white would have settled for a draw
so Luke g8 that's a pretty pretty hard
to make decision so this and now he took
on a form well you know I mean if you
are black here yeah you argue let's say
worst possible scenario yeah worst
scenario you lose both pawns that could
happen very much yeah
then right only chance to win is to push
here yeah push the pawns and that is not
easy to do he has no other pawns left
this is so important when we're taking
with the attack in the a pawn is so so
important because if white would have
managed a five and winning six then he
had chances to push the a pawn all the
way through without weakening the King
and here any sort of wind would involve
blunders okay yeah but any sort of like
let's say forced wind or systemic wind
would involve those pawns to be pushed
and that's not easy to do so maybe maybe
the rationale but black was that this is
maybe better for white when it's very
difficult to really realize into a full
point because you would have to weaken
yourself a lot to do that it's not
easier at all for white to get ahead you
have no safe spot for the king and maybe
maybe but like has chances to push his
pawns
at some point maybe one of the plants
points yeah and it's interesting that's
a very interesting choice so Queen to e7
was played Queen to g6 and look f8
hmm does it make sense to try to rule
well it's tough to say sometimes you can
really say it pretty clearly like here
you should trade a rook or not that's
tough to say here so let's see how it
happened so we got this trade 27 and now
h5 and this is now the pawn that gets
the counter player now this must be
where the engine is on equal I have
which which helps with fine eval but it
it makes sense yeah it makes sense that
black is okay now this is not easy to
attack and you push the edge pawn
nice that's really nice
yeah it's sometimes funny here the
engine gives all 0ci like every single
move is a zero yeah but it's still so
easy to find moves that are not zero
okay look g1 played by Khurana
pinning the bishop and E for played so
this is of course a calculation or
nightmare if you're in this to calculate
all that it's difficult yeah I can tell
you for sure that I would probably lose
this with boss Carlos he I would make
some some wacky calculation mistake so
if R is played and even is 3 and we can
we got to that scenario that White has
gotten those pawns but and if you look
at this year and if the the final moves
is never moving them is we move c4 at
some point and then they make a draw I
want to set the full game did they
really make a draw here
it looks like a weird position to make a
draw and you know ok can you confirm
that that this is the final position
okay cool and we have a look at this in
a moment but I just wondered if this is
something there's something missing
okay so here Queen f5 yes stepping
outside of this pin which is kind of
logical so okay Queen d6 must not play a
volume yeah okay
upon a su not not not should not be
taken a eight came to age seven twenty
eight
it's definitely white here who needs to
hold the draw all those pawns are too
dangerous then white has to be precise
and I mean currently actually those
points are purely cover pawns for the
King they can never promote and black is
actually playing with everything that he
has so I think that was a pretty good
decision for my MIDI are off to play
this on yeah it's just all them all the
trouble is with with white I mean it's
not that like it's easy to play but
white has to be I think even more more
cautious here one screw-up can easily
lose Queen to e6 and g6
ah thanks for Sookie McNugget says that
he bought my evo repertoire ingestible
today yeah thanks a lot for for doing
that I hope you will enjoy it
so g6 one
qg7
and now they they go for them for the
game position so what takes takes
life-form
Bishop g3 try to group here Wow
and this is exactly a drawing so easy
for the engine so difficult for us so
age 4 and now king c2 is supposedly a
draw so this they they are not you're
not making any headway am that's true
like before I thought king e5
I am b5 I'm sorry h3 king of Chun I can
you can get to this yeah wear those
pants do protect one another and
basically I mean yeah this is an
important motif you cannot take f4 as
then the point here promotes and if
white tries to try to do this then all
of a sudden you have screwed screwed
yourself yeah
no you whatever you do we are you and
now the other point to promote so here
White has to simply stay ok so that was
not that difficult to see for those
people yeah and the drone nice one nice
one
yes that's cool yeah you boom marked in
FM now I understand your handle he says
he's becoming a big fan of GUI shock his
press conferences are hilarious yes I
think Richard is really funny right he's
got this totally deadpan humor he's
sitting there like and then he's just
firing yeah really nice and fine I
thought it was crazy that he mentioned
after his loss in the first round
playing conditions are terrible that's
not even water on the toilets this is
fantastic
it's fantastic I really I really love it
[Laughter]
okay just a moment I need to need a bit
of fresh TM that was really really cool
so it was really a tough game but I
don't feel like I have yeah I've really
understood it yeah it's just tough very
very tough so we had this lame game so
ding kayaking very shocked what was that
ah there was this game
yeah you know if you see this opening
play yeah it's either the no underage
championship of Berlin or it is the
candidates in Berlin I don't want to
analyze this game that is a little bit
boring you know maybe one little detail
and this is in fact somewhat important I
have once prepared with black here for
this position and it's it's good to see
that Grisha plays aged six because this
is just better than d6 I know it sounds
a bit wacky dee's 60 are the full
symmetry but I actually believe that
white has a slight pool after Bishop g5
I know it sounds weird but I think you
have a slight pool there with what it's
maybe a Jewish of course and so on but I
didn't feel it is so comfortable I once
had to prepare this with black against
GM yeah there was a GM and we're dissing
his repertoire and I was really
wondering like what that's that's like
weird that he somebody would play that
but one reason is that this is indeed a
little bit of an initiative I mean a
little bit and you you should just play
aged 60 mm my comer would be proud play
aged six not to prevent this but to
prevent Bishop g5 now and only go d6
next month this is exactly what Chris
Rock did and now we have this this real
snoozer of a position there but it's
what it is it's just what it is you
cannot really do much against white
players playing like that kayaking tried
94 try to get the bishop palette yeah
this is not really all that all that
exciting of course there is a question
byaku Leon what to do I think about
argon this is a interesting question and
my answer is probably a little bit you
know I can tell it like it is
I never really put much thought about
this I felt what they did before the
organization of the World Championship
matches like the match in New York and
and other things that certainly could
have done better
of course but there's one fact here that
I need to mention I'm going to be in
Berlin starting on Friday and I'm going
to do commentary on site the German
commentary German language commentary so
in some way I'm hired by are gone there
to do that job in Berlin and therefore I
feel I shouldn't really bash them or all
that much yeah they they hired me to to
do some job for them I have not I have
not seen them in person what they did
what they do in Berlin the the messages
received like on reddit and others here
like Greece you're complaining about the
toilet sisters and sound all that well
we'll see what happens at at the actual
venue when I'm there it's it's just that
I was asked before that event like month
ago if I would be interested in doing
the commentary at the candidates and I'm
not I'm not seeing anybody declining
that it's just a great thing it's a
great experience I'm going to be a on
site doing commentary together with Ilya
and Sarah Gatzke who you maybe know
especially the German audience will know
him from his days at chest when you form
it some it's it just said I just felt I
have to do it yeah it's it's a I've been
at the candidates in London which was a
fantastic experience and I really think
I mean you've been there as a visitor
and I really felt this is a fantastic
tournament the candidates is for me the
most interesting tournament in the year
in some way more interesting than the
match so I assume he had to take that
opportunity
with argan oil or verges or whatever
yeah I wasn't thinking so much about
that I was thinking about yet doing a
job that I love to do for the tournament
that is just so interesting to to to
work at so I took this job it doesn't
sound like they've done a particularly
great job I mean but we'll we'll see
we'll see maybe they also improve some
things and and it will get better yeah
you know what hit the toilets what kind
of thing is that so we will see I will
give you some some update on the toilet
situation when I'm at that place so
we've looked a little bit at the games
of today's round um is there anything
else that you wanted to look at like
from yesterday or something if not I
would play just a couple of games
against you guys and then call it a day
the other thing that I that I could show
you if you like I can tell you a little
bit about my new repertoire that is
going that is released on chesil today
and that's also something that I could
do if you like but it's your call this
is a live show that is for the viewers
it's not not for me I want to do
something that interests you so sorry so
some games I got some challenges so
let's play some games
let's go from top to bottom
Marco Rico is playing it against the car
oh I have the two nights variation
that's my recommendation speaking of the
car oh okay
let's do something funny this move is
better than it looks
I want to take there and play Bishop f5
and give me some good place to go to on
h7 for the Bishop it was better than it
looks which is not it's not difficult
because it looks a weird it's not bad
okay this looks okay
again Audion asked if I would be my I be
willing to show my game against rust him
in horde from yesterday I have not yet
entered that game actually to show in a
database and I'm not sure that I would
want to show it in some way I really
have to get to terms with that game a
little bit more i I lost that game
yesterday and it was a game that was
very weird in a way because I lost it
due to a type of missile calculation
that that I never had never in my whole
years of playing chess I am I simply
sacrificed a piece and I I look I
calculated a variation and the piece
that I wanted to place I wanted to play
Bishop g7 takes two on d4 this move was
simply not possible because the bishop
wasn't on g7 but on f8 so I had a
complete hallucination I mean I was
simply not seeing the board correctly
and this is something that I have never
experienced absolutely never and I don't
really know what to make of it the worst
part was that in the position where i
blundered the piece and i was thinking I
would sacrifice a piece and he resigns
basically because I thought it was over
in that position basically any
reasonable move was completely winning
because White's position was already in
ruins yeah it was absolutely terrible
position for white so basically anything
but what I did would have won the game
it was just like I mean I have of course
miscalculated yeah I've seen things
wrong like okay I thought this would be
possible and then I didn't look at one
position right or whatever but I have
absolutely never never thought okay I'm
going to play this move and then I
actually look at the board and think
wait
there is no Bishop on g7 it was really
hard yeah I think yeah well it was
stranger it was a really strange
experience and the game I think was not
in itself wasn't super interesting
because honestly I'm yeah where Poland
just played some very weird moves that I
basically refuted easily and then then i
blundered the piece it was just a very
weird game so let's have a look at this
game against Marco Rico I need to get my
night out a cool Ian asked if my before
series is easier to learn than the c4
series um depends depends the e4 series
is different in some ways first of all
one important difference is that it has
less of transpositions the c-4 series
just by nature is full of transpositions
there are ways to there are ways to get
to a certain position in four or five
times four times different ways or
have to when you play c4 and D goes
tonight f6 and you play g3 this has
far-reaching consequences in some cases
where you simply have to take into
account okay if I do that now yeah I
have to really look for this in that
kind of scenario and with e4 it is a bit
easier in some way because they are not
that many trans positions if you start
with the French defense it's not all of
a sudden going to transpose into e45
that doesn't happen or caro-kann doesn't
all of a sudden transpose into a
Sicilian so in some ways it is more
straightforward one difference is it's a
little bit easier it's a little bit
easier to UM to learn maybe because in
chess abour we have those we have the
variations and we have we have
alternative lines and informational
lines and the áfourá patois does not
have alternative lines or informational
lines if you have used chess to go
before and you will know what I'm
talking about um I have simply not
offered alternative lines by using
actual lines in chasuble but if I've
just mentioned them in the text that
makes the actual learning easier yeah so
there are some differences that that you
will certainly experience I'm not sure
if that makes it easier to learn it
really depends a little bit also on
maybe what you what you know beforehand
and what you what you really completely
learn as a new new line I have should be
five lines against the Sicilian yes
there was a question what is a typical
Club player there's not in terms of
strength this is not so easy to say I
usually would
would say something around 1600 1700 you
play in a chess club you you are a
little bit ambitious to play in
otherwise you wouldn't get such a
repertoire or any any other book
something something like that okay how
do I win this position this is a good
question you know not easy
hmm I don't know how to win maybe I
can't I try to regroup the bit of the
night night to see five is my idea and
then maybe Queenie six okay there's a
little bit of a weakness
okay queen - f - not sure that I can win
this position okay now my night is
approaching
it said this is increment uh and I'm so
hectic I'm sorry I was really thinking
this is a 3-0 okay then I would have
approached that differently i was so
happy to go Kim let's make it wrong
ah no it wasn't good I didn't see that
it was increment I was really thinking
okay I'm losing on time I have to play
super quick moves and it really wasn't
the case and there's one thing that I
definitely wanted to mention to you and
this is something that is coming up
shortly a tournament on D chess instead
actually already in there somehow it's
going to be on Wednesday do you already
see that yeah I don't know nope ah here
it is here we have a tournament a 1e
forum thematic tournament this
tournament is going to be played on
Wednesday evening Wednesday at 11 p.m.
Central European Time so pretty late
German time and this is a really nice
one we are going to play only one e4
it's a little bit of a celebration
tournament of the new Chesterville
release and we will even have some
prizes sponsored by fishy fishy he likes
my stream so he was very generous to
donate some money to get out and give
out as prizes so we're going to play
this tournament I'm going to stream that
tournament doing commentary it will be
blitz and I will make commentary on the
top level games and makes it a bit more
relaxed for me and I have to don't have
to play myself so I know it's a bit late
but fishy fishy fishy himself wanted it
to be late so I felt as I should
accomplish that I should accept that
yeah
okay so make sure to watch that I'm
going to put that out of course they get
on my channel on that day okay I'm going
to play pad six five seven eight so pair
to give it a go going to play the French
defense that I recently briefly checked
it's not a bad opening the Fort Knox
variation again in the French one of the
better lines yeah this is roughly equal
already I'm I've traded two sets of
minor pieces and I've gotten rid of my
LightSquared Bishop if you have ever
played the Scandinavian you might have
had similar positions yeah that's true
that's a very easy to play variation for
black it's not the most exciting line
ever have that Fort Knox variation but
it is definitely something you can try
yeah colognian you're right is really
the case that the US is totally
different in terms of club chairs one
thing that you really have to check
there you have you have lots of areas
that are yeah non-urban really like out
in the countryside and those they simply
don't have any chairs infrastructure
they have no clubs or nothing and
sometimes not even some good players
that
they judge they have nothing I've
checked I would be number one in many US
states actually a myth my rating and
this is also why I'm sometimes
approached by some us some players for
for training because they because they
don't have anybody in their own vicinity
that they could ask and over your teaser
of my recommended alliance in yes
but my my youtube channel will have lots
of teaser videos yeah so currently there
is a video out a ten minute video on the
e45 sidelines and if you follow the link
given in the video you would actually
get to the full video so you can already
watch 1 hour 25 minutes roughly of the
very first chapter
so we have the chasuble the moves here
and you can get the full video for the
first chapter
yeah Patterson are trying to find how
the videos are a really nice add-on and
they are very young they are very nicely
integrated into the chest of a platform
and I think them you don't necessarily
need the video but it is helpful in some
way because you have the added
possibilities given with the video for
example you can easily watch the video
completely independent of the chasuble
site let's say I mean you have to watch
it on the side you don't download it but
it is some it is so very nice because
you might want to just do something not
interactive just get some info under on
the lines and do that maybe while
sitting on the couch or something okay
while they are explaining all that I
have established control over t5 this is
nice to have I'm also taking his bishop
so I've created pretty nice pawn
structure yeah I'm quite happy its
attack
I don't know about the plans for and the
plans for apps by chasuble I really
don't know I'm not I'm mostly involved
with the content creation and I've been
involved of course with the ins and outs
of the video platform that like I was
involved in building it in a way that
that I liked it let's say and I was
testing it and so on but I don't really
know what the priority is some with
potentially with with an app I don't
know okay I definitely don't want to
blunder my upon but it is supported
currently by the Salone range Bishop so
that's very nice
maybe I can get the default one I didn't
recommend the exchange French I
absolutely do yeah c5 was hanging yeah
thanks for the gamepad okay who else is
on new Vaughn Raymond
Sonja Vaughn Yvonne good luck yes let's
try that again
I really happen to test it
chasuble much on anything else than a
normal browser let's same folks that
you're funny the exchange French is so
exciting she says and I actually don't
think it is super exciting but it I
think it's a really underestimated
practical weapon it has some real pluses
a deep tournament on the French exchange
I would probably squawk wide well they
already know stuff now about it what is
he doing here
395 yeah that's true Kasparov played the
French exchange
I do recommend to play with c4 against
Bishop d6 yes against that it is really
good line c-4 another situation it's not
a good line okay um you know you're you
should run if you play a line like the
French exchange with what is that black
players will be reacting in in various
ways and all of them in all of them are
likely to be good for white they might
think you're playing for draw oh my god
this is boring why is he playing this
stuff
whatever yeah and this is a good thing
because you they might think they have
an easy draw now at hand or they might
think nothing will ever happen but it
doesn't it's just not the case there are
things happening it's just that they are
a little bit too subtle for some people
to understand and if you really look at
this a little bit you can set problems
you can set problems I mean I have
played it now once in tournament chess
and very easily beaded FM with it I mean
very easily it's it is a sports board
option people hate to play against it
and also you know I have some experience
with teaching teaching people chess and
it is very common it is very common that
that people who play one year form
actually struggle with the French
defense and the reason is that in the
French defense black wants a closed game
and some people playing white who
usually want an open position they are
actually absolutely not
really they don't play those variations
well simply they play the French
sometimes not well I have this problem
with many of my chest students that they
tell me are I don't have a good line
against the French and I was looking at
many things I can tell you I've looked
at the tirage and whatever and I felt
that in most cases you're just playing
into into black's hands because they get
their typical closed position where they
can move their pieces around and shuffle
and whatnot and why give them their
structures so easily I thought it is a
very practical way to play rook to b5
what is this going to do funny move okay
let me take this
I didn't see that one coming but I have
a tool now it looks like his piece a
little bit overworked here okay - I can
take take on b6 that's going to be
difficult how does he come with a book I
should win here think okay yeah thanks
for the game you have an arraignment
okay so let's go spy 77 what is the spy
up to and by the way one thing I wanted
to to mention because we are discussing
this repertoire chasuble has a very very
nice I think
refund policy whatever you buy you can
get your money back in a certain period
of time I'm not sure how much it is two
weeks one week I don't know I don't know
how much it is but you can get full
refunds on everything that you buy every
single dollar you get back or euro or
whatever if you don't like the product
so if you feel you're uncertain or
anything just give it a go and you can
easily get it back if you dislike the
product so this is I think an important
thing I think the the learning platform
combined with the video and also the non
video platform if you want to if you
don't think you need the video is great
but it's still something that if you
don't know it it's a little bit it is
different to what you are used to in
traditional books so you can test it and
if you like it you can keep and use it
or you can get a full refund if you
don't like it I really believe that you
can learn the things they are very
nicely in a very nice way in fact what I
did is I mean I've written the whole
thing but some of the lines I have
written half a year ago and I have
looked at it again and updated and so on
but it's not like I can just easily
reproduce if you just show me a position
every single move every single thing but
I'm of course for the videos I had to go
through all the lines and present them
so what I actually did to learn
everything and to be be a better
presenter of the whole stuff I learned
the whole repertoire again or chest over
move by move I've been going through all
the 700 variations and now I know other
stuff I mean I really do yeah speaking
of stuff I need this sexier yeah I
played lots of evil over the board
recently I'm I've I'm mixing it it
depends a little bit on the opponent I
play I played before fifty-fifty let's
say with other moves recently in some
cases I cannot resist you to play em to
play see 490 or 3 if they if they give
me a like a King's Indian to play
against or so I'm going to go with Dee
for openings but in some cases if I was
tempting it depends a lot on what I
expect the other guy to play
that is an awkward pin on the night
hmm that's it so that's odd
it isn't that great not not that good
either thorium
okay thanks for the GameSpy 77 it's a
bit of an early resignation but okay
let's go with Jessie and I'm going to go
for one or more one or two more games
oh no I'm not sponsored by ditches
ditches doesn't do sponsorship I mean if
you want it is one such a because a
while ago some some month ago I think
ditch has contacted a couple of regulars
who use the site a lot and they sent me
this as a gift so I'm not sure what it
is in the store I think maybe twenty to
thirty dollars or so it's nice it's a
nice quality item but it's some I
wouldn't call it sponsorship they don't
really pay out money or anything like
that okay against Jesse I'm trying to
play for a quick King side action let's
see what I'm doing here
whenever I say action I really I really
would want to like to be able to
pronounce it like Arnold Schwarzenegger
- yeah this is the he has this weird
Austrian way of pronouncing it I think
it's brilliant yeah but I cannot I
cannot copy it yeah I would really love
to do it and I cannot do it like action
it's impossible to do action swim yeah
something like that
okay what i'm doing here is i'm hoping
that jesse at some point plays you for
this h4 point is so annoying and i would
love to get the free view on that bishop
oh that's interesting
okay you get a 30-day money-back
guarantee i did not know that action
swim yes
it's close to it yeah sure
I mean there will definitely be more
repertoire us coming I love to do those
and I think Ray the format is great I'm
not sure what I'm going to do next it's
quite likely actually that before I
decide on a new project I'm going to
there will be some sort of some sort of
poll on not pronouncing it right I know
okay now you can do they have a money
back policy also for the products I'm
totally sure Gloria thanks for looking
it up but I mean I really know because
the boss of chasuble told me that you
can return the books if you don't like
them all of a sudden my bishop is
getting great before a new repertoire is
going to be started however the keep it
simple if for repertoire is going to be
released as a paper book this is an
additional thing that's going to happen
I have today actually today signed the
contract with you and chest to make a
paper book out of it so this will be
released later this year and once this
is finished it's not that much
additional work actually because it is
some the repertoire as it is released
now on chasuble it's basically a book it
just it just needs a little bit of yeah
polishing let's say to to make it a
paper book you need stuff like a table
of contents for example or you need you
need an intro text and something
yes the text is readable yeah I'm not
sure I mean I'm not really that involved
with the refund policy I just know that
yeah David the boss of chasuble told me
that it's returnable but if that is not
so clearly stated they should probably
be clearer there I think it makes a lot
of sense to have this kind of policy
even if you are confident about the
product I mean I think it's a good
customer service
okay so we have to see that this is not
us has increments so I'm not just going
to win on time folks here wants an
e-book on file structures and well what
is wrong with Florez Rios book on
structures I mean I don't know that this
is not maybe what you what you would
find under ebook but this is probably
what you want in terms of content chest
structures by Flores Rios yeah and now
after the Queen trade almost unavoidable
Jessi resigns okay I think one more game
and then I'm calling today high wind
fantasies let's go with that okay I was
really varying well there oh no no now
some really obscure stuff is played
the this is a ready line right B 3 is
ready ready and now they trade okay yeah
thanks for the game Jesse
yeah here I'm going to play castle c6
and so on one issue for the white is a
little bit how are you going to place
your pawns here the dnc pawn if you play
d4 you're killing this bishop if you
play d3 okay now he's killed the bishop
on b7 a on b2 I'm sorry I really okay so
why is that even possible
it's not good
Thomas is hosting my stream and I'm not
really this hosting is not really
something I know but I guess it's a good
thing to be hosted it sounds very
positive
if he castles now I'm going to go
creature h4
what is he doing now I'm threatening
mate 93r doesn't work and after age
three Knight takes e5 I'm just winning
this pawn yes I think I'm just winning
this pawn I don't see why I shouldn't
win the pawn yeah he's got he's got a
little bit of development going for him
I'm not sure that he's lost as suggested
in the chat it's a big center horn and
it's not really enough compensation but
he's got his pieces out so
2197 f/8 and then trade on the iPhone
I've got lots of black games yeah did
they change challenge me to Blackey
games I don't know I didn't really do
anything to get to get this
pin and win
yeah I'm going to win some material here
right
now I'm going to win some material
hmm
yeah thanks for the game high wind
fantasies so going to close this stream
now it's been a really long day
today a very happy day actually due to
the release of this long-awaited product
but it was still lots of work I've done
the candidates coverage in the early in
the in the first part of the stream if
you want to watch it again this show
after it is closed will be archived in
the video section of the channel so you
can watch that there yeah thanks a lot
for taking part make sure to go and
watch my tournament here on beaches on
Wednesday the hoodie you can get in the
in the DHS swag store I think it is cold
yeah um yeah let's call it a day thanks
a lot for all you thanks a lot to all of
you bye bye